seguimos siempre las 24 hablando de
economía y volvemos con nuestra
periodista ni el hablando aunque nos va
a hacer una ampliación de lo que ha
pasado hoy en esta materia
el banco mundial daniel ascendió las
alertas por el aumento de la pobreza
educativa en américa latina' si liliana
de dice algo muy cierto y es que la
pobreza ocasionada por el kobe de 1990
económica el banco mundial llama la
atención a los gobiernos a que también
analicen los retrasos académicos que
traen consigo la pandemia y advierte que
la crisis podría llevar a los sistemas
educativos de américa latina y el caribe
de regreso a los años 60 para
cuantificar esa pérdida de aprendizaje
en términos de ingresos el organismo
hace el siguiente ejercicio de liliana
suponiendo que un alumno promedio pierde
10 meses de clase presencial deja de
recibir en promedio 1300 dólares anuales
en ingresos a lo largo de su vida
esto porque pierde productividad ya la
vez ingresos cuando inició la pandemia
unos 1600 millones de estudiantes habían
dejado de asistir a la escuela en el
mundo de ese total más de 170 millones
se encontraban en américa latina'
daniela y el presidente mexicano amenaza
con cambiar la constitución de la
polémica reforma eléctrica impulsada por
el mandatario está enredada en los
tribunales
andrés manuel lópez obrador advirtió que
si éstos declaran su
inconstitucionalidad estaría dispuesto a
ejecutar un plan ver de qué se trata
escuchemos yo estoy seguro que no es
inconstitucional pero sí
no determinan jueces magistrados
ministros de que es inconstitucional y
que no puede
y proceder enviaría yo una iniciativa de
reforma a la constitución porque no
puedo ser cómplice
del robo vale la pena recordar que esa
reforma que ya fue aprobada por el
congreso ha sido controversial porque
los detractores denuncian que incentiva
la producción de energía no renovable
pero el gobierno defiende que privilegia
el interés estatal sobre el privado
lanier y la reserva federal mejoró
drásticamente sus previsiones económicas
en eeuu liviana terminó este miércoles
la esperada reunión mensual de dos días
de la autoridad económica de este país
con mensajes muy alentadores en primer
lugar cree que el producto interno bruto
va a crecer 65 % este año esto
representa una significativa revisión al
alza desde el 4,2 por ciento anterior
gracias en parte al paquete de estímulo
económico aprobado recientemente
escuchamos el empleo está 9,5 millones
por debajo del nivel pre pandémico el
desempleo sigue siendo elevado con 62
por ciento en febrero más allá de esto
también podría verse una presión al alza
sobre los precios si el gasto se
recupera rápidamente a medida que la
economía continúa reabriéndose
y la yerba mate llegará entonces al
mercado de la india liliana o intensas
negociaciones por varios meses entre las
autoridades de argentina y de la india
en julio de 2020 la delegación india
había concluido la evaluación de los
documentos presentados por el servicio
sanitario argentino y también el
análisis de riesgo de pestes finalmente
el país asiático dio el visto bueno
definitivo para importar yerba mate
argentina en varias presentaciones que
pueden ser en sacos o en bolsas también
a granel o en forma de té
esto puede darles un buen impulso a las
exportaciones argentinas de yerba mate y
sus derivados que en 2020 fueron de 94
millones de dólares y crecieron cerca
del 10 por ciento hoy en día los
principales destinos de este producto
son medio oriente y chile pero ahora
argentina va a intentar conquistar este
mercado que es de más de 1.200 millones
de personas la harina y háblenos ahora
de los indicadores de la jornada
liliana wall street dow jones subió
import impulsada por los anuncios de la
fed su principal índice el dow jones de
industriales- marcó un nuevo récord el
mercado europeo no alcanzó
con las decisiones de la reserva federal
y antes del cierre pues terminó con poco
movimiento y en latinoamérica el mercado
mexicano cerró negativo después de siete
sesiones al alza y finalizamos con la
cita del día 138 millones de dólares la
cadena hotelera más grande de españa
amelia presentó una demanda contra el
gobierno ante un tribunal administrativo
y busca una compensación por los daños
ocasionados por las restricciones del
cobi 19 en 2020 se estima que más de 40
400 varios restaurantes y hoteles ya han
presentado reclamos con la misma
intención de recibir compensaciones por
el tiempo que permanecieron cerrados en
la pandemia necesaria la por la
información de colombia y a ustedes
gracias continúen con más entradas 24
puntos com y también quédense aquí con
nosotros